Hey, everyone.
Tesla CEO Elon Musk is not a fan of LIDAR
- the laser sensor used by many autonomous
car companies to navigate the world.
LIDAR is a fool’s errand and anyone relying
on LIDAR is doomed.
LIDAR stands for Light Detection and Ranging.
The sensor emits pulsed light waves into the
environment.
They bounce off surrounding objects and return
back to the sensor.
The sensor uses the time it took for each
pulse to return to the sensor to calculate
the distance it traveled.
Repeating this a million times a second helps
create a 3D map of the environment.
If the LIDAR detects it’s getting close
to an object, it’ll apply the brakes to
slow down the vehicle.
Practically everyone other than Tesla views
LIDAR as essential.
Alphabet's Waymo – seen as one of the frontrunners
of self-driving - uses LIDAR.
GM’s self-driving unit Cruise acquired its
own LIDAR manufacturer a few years ago.
Apple’s rumored smart car is said to be
looking for the sensor.
One reason Musk doesn’t like LIDAR is that
it’s expensive.
It’s like having a whole bunch of expensive
appendices.
One appendix is bad. Well, now we're going to put a whole bunch of them.
That’s ridiculous.
You’ll see.
LIDAR used to be very expensive, costing tens
of thousands of dollars.
But now, LIDAR units can be thousands of dollars
or under $1,000.
And manufacturers aspire to reduce costs to
the low hundreds in the future.
Supporters of LIDAR argue it can do things
cameras cannot.
While cameras interpret depth, LIDAR precisely
measures distances.
It’s trusted by NASA to do everything from
studying changes to glaciers to collecting
data over the Amazon rainforest.
However, Musk argues that LIDAR cannot fully
capture the quirks of the real world.
He’s called it a crutch.
Whereas Tesla’s approach to self-driving
is to rely on cameras in the way humans depend
on vision to drive.
To use just computer vision, it would have
to understand an image in the way we understand
an image with our eyes and brain.
Musk thinks it can be done.
Which begs the question: Why was Tesla spotted
with LIDAR?
An autonomous vehicle consultant recently
posted these photos on Twitter of a Model
Y that was sporting LIDAR in Florida.
According to a report by Automotive News,
Tesla has a contract with LIDAR manufacturer
Luminar Technologies though neither Luminar
nor Tesla has confirmed it.
I don’t think that they’ll ever actually use LIDAR on their production vehicles.
I spoke with Sam Abuelsamid, an analyst with
Guidehouse Insights, who believes Tesla is
simply using LIDAR for training purposes.
If your machine vision system is saying there’s
a vehicle 50  m away from you in the lane to
your right, you want to have something to
use to verify that the software is calculating
that correctly, and that’s what LIDAR does very well.
He says if Tesla were to change its mind and
incorporate LIDAR, that would be problematic
for its fleet of a million existing vehicles.
Musk assured customers that their Teslas already
had all the hardware necessary for full self-driving.
In the same way Tesla feels it doesn’t need
LIDAR, it’s also doing away with radar.
Tesla’s website used to refer to radar for
its driver assistance system, Autopilot.
However, the references to radar have recently
been dropped.
The company confirmed Model 3s and Model Ys
delivered to the North American market are
no longer equipped with radar.
Model S and Model Xs will eventually make
the transition too as will cars destined for
other markets.
Tesla says new vehicles without radar will
have Autopilot temporarily limited to lower
speeds and a longer minimum following distance
and will lose a few other functions.
Removing radar isn’t surprising.
Musk tweeted in 2018 that “Long-term, the
car will work purely on vision”.
The company is going all in on what it calls
“Tesla Vision” where Autopilot and full
self-driving - its most advanced driver assistance
system - will rely purely on camera vision
and neural net processing.
This is what Tesla Autopilot sees using neural
networks that analyze the vehicle’s surroundings.
The aim is for Tesla’s artificial intelligence
technologies to propel its system from Level
2 autonomy all the way to Level 5 in which
a driver would become a passenger.
There would be no steering wheel or brakes.
Tesla believes that is possible without radar
or LIDAR though some analysts question whether
that’s the best move.
Although Algolux is a company that focuses
on using cameras for autonomous driving, an
executive there tells me relying solely on
cameras may not be the best option:
Dave Tokic says “…it may be short-sighted
to not leverage additional sensor modalities,
especially new breakthroughs in radar…as
well as Lidar if the market can absorb it.”
Despite his adamant belief that LIDAR will
be unnecessary, Musk once admitted: Perhaps
I am wrong, and I will look like a fool.
But I am quite certain that I am not.
Tesla is relying heavily on artificial intelligence
as it prepares for a driverless future.
There’s a fascinating class on Skillshare
about how machine learning and AI are shaping
our world.
My sponsor Skillshare offers thousands of
inspiring classes on a whole host of topics
- which you can try out for FREE.
MKBHD has great tips on how to grow a YouTube
channel.
Polymatter has a class on how to make animated
videos.
Each class is broken up into short lessons,
there are no ads, and it’s for all skill
levels.
The first 1,000 of my subscribers to click
the link in my description will get a complimentary
trial of Premium Membership so you can explore
your creativity.
For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.